Are we watching a bromance unfold in real
time, or was there something else going on
between Pedro Pascal and Kieran Culkin?
Here's why Pascal was slinging shade at Culkin
at the Emmys.
Viewers of the 75th Primetime Emmy Awards
may have done a double-take when Pedro Pascal
showed up with his arm in a sling, but they
did a triple-take when he called out Kieran
Culkin completely out of the blue.
Pascal took to the podium to present an award
and opened by saying:
"Before we get into the nominees for best
supporting actor in a drama series, I'd like
to take just a second and make this about
me.
A lot of people have been asking about my
arm."
The broadcast censored the punchline of his
story, but the uncensored clip on YouTube
clarified what he said.
Pascal continued:
"It's actually my shoulder, and I think this
is the perfect time to tell everyone that
Kieran Culkin beat the s— out of me."
Immediately after, the cameras treated viewers
to a close-up of a stone-faced Culkin staring
at Pascal.
Audiences got a laugh, and a few seconds later
Culkin cracked a smile as well.
Awards shows are full of friendly jabs between
actors, but still…what was that all about?
First of all, no — Culkin didn't really
beat up Pascal.
At least, probably not.
On January 7, the actor told reporters that
he'd accidentally fallen.
His Emmys joke played out more like a bit
of joking revenge.
At the 2024 Golden Globes, Pascal and Culkin
were both nominated for the Golden Globe for
best performance by an actor in a drama series
for their work on "The Last of Us" and "Succession."
Culkin won and took a jab of his own at Pascal
in his acceptance speech.
He said:
"Thanks to 'Succession' I've been in here
a couple times.
It's nice, but I sort of accepted I was never
going to be on the stage.
So this is a nice moment.
Suck it, Pedro."
Even this wasn't the beginning of the friendly
sniping between the pair.
It's merely the latest chapter in what's shaping
up to be an endearing bromance between two
of the hottest actors in Hollywood.
In 2023, the actors sat side by side during
The Hollywood Reporter's roundtable discussion
along with Jeff Bridges, Evan Peters, Michael
Imperioli, and Damson Idris . Throughout,
he and Pascal demonstrated an easy chemistry
that at times resembled a seasoned comedy act.
"Amazingly, it gave me the opportunity to
be able to go and do something else."
"That's good.
Do you ever…"
It looks like the two have decided to continue
the fun and games throughout the awards season.
Though Pascal once again lost out to Culkin
when they were up for the same award at the
Emmys, cameras captured the two meeting up
in a crowd at the afterparty, where they appeared
to be on perfectly good terms, laughing and
smiling for the cameras.
One video posted to X showed Culkin reaching
up to pat Pascal on the right shoulder — his
injured one — leading Pascal to not-so-subtly
move the hand to his good shoulder.
Fans have been loving the dynamic between
Pascal and Culkin the whole time.
After Pascal's joke at the Emmys, fans took
to social media to share their love for the
duo's dynamic.
One person wrote:
"The real winner is us witnessing the evolution
of the duo that is pedro pascal + kieran culkin."
Meanwhile, another person compared their dynamic
to some other fan-favorite celebrity friendships, writing,
"Kieran Culkin & Pedro Pascal are the new
Ryan Reynolds & Hugh Jackman, The Rock & Kevin
Hart, Ken Jeong & Joel McHale."
Another X user expressed hope that the decision
makers in Hollywood were taking note of the
obvious chemistry between Pascal and Culkin.
Finally, one user had just a single humble
request, writing:
"I wish every award season could include kieran
culkin and pedro pascal."
Whether they're winning trophies or just razzing
each other on stage, we too would like to
see more of Pedro Pascal and Kieran Culkin's
antics at future award shows.